n ame
hey んだそうだ
twitter でも見てみるか勉強なえらいぞがんばれー
今日は弾み社長で妻というわけで今年ももう12月
終わりでございますね全体でいる振替にはもっと年末にするとして僕の
スマートフォンのローが振り返っていきましょうぼく何したっけなんか前昔も
にっていうの曲寄ったんですよねあの僕で毎年交戦していこうかなと思いまして明日
いいけどだしたらぜって炎上するしなあかんね何か言われそうな動画見たいのを我慢し
てスマホで撮って自分で友達と楽しいんでるんですよあもう今年2010年も結構
いろんな
end た末端でをはそれはみんな見ていこうかなと思いますなかなか足のや見せられ
ないよねつもあるんですけどもまぁ年末だからいっ
はいトリマーを順番に見ていきましょうこれだけ五彩池なんですけどなんかウイングに
入ったらとミックさんが中に持って暴れてて
のコイツって思ってか2年間お腹空いてるかなと思って数組のお礼
じゃジップはさについてあげたんですけどそしたらなんかとミクさんが花にハサミを
入れてみようみたいなこと言い出して名より
カニのはさみお花が罠に入れられている動画で好きだから
[音楽]
はい臭い臭いハードだなぁスペッ
素早くからみんなも僕
いた pt ipad いやーこれら自伝た方とミカン
ぞそんなことしないでくださいメカ23ほら舌や数組握ったまま横移動していくって
いう
何やってんだかこれはの寿司屋さんに行った時の動画ですねこれはの俺なんもやって
ないんですけど
なんぼやってるんですけど気付い者なんか厚焼き玉子がこう
重体になっている
であのっ
突っかかってるなぁと思って何考えてはどうなるんだろうとから次のほとんど生き
ちゃって
まあ大変だなぁと思ってみまーす動画ですあの
この後裏の中底たが直したんで大丈夫ですはいえーこれはですね今年度忙しかったと
聞いがあって夏ですね東京で
を剃らなかった夏時間寝てて撮ってる動画です僕と一緒で
口を開けて寝るタイプみたいですね
[音楽]
大きされました渡口上にいるときに何か
あの脅かせ落としてやってたやつですか
いたところ驚かせるっていうわー
あああああなんといいねあとこれはベースでタクシーで移動2の時に寝てるた夏ですね
この夏は忙しかったんでね寝ることがよくありました
[音楽]
津波て大変なのでこれ無理寝てるな方起こそうとする
これです
[音楽]
の弾み帰るね一君帰っちゃうってなもん
バイバイわ
[音楽]
始めて帰っちゃってあっ一君帰っちゃうって
ございません
なってるんでしょ入ってを議論だこれなんだっけこれ
あそうだあの太郎あ野球議論入ってるやつをあの横から絶叫してあげてました
本当にこれ切る入ってるんですって気持ち悪かったんですけどなんかね
せっかくなんで記念に取ろうかなと思って後ろから10とってます
[音楽]
なもし
肩を上げています
[音楽]
だけを数0起きたらしかもじゃないよ
ただまぁそさんがスプラトゥーンの実況で止めようって言ってるのがすごいなんか
印象深かったんで動画とってました
ん
食べ過ぎて白吐きそうになった時ですよなんだっけここ2人が後輩2人で
な横断歩道が出て酒ないって言ったんですけど今じゃくざけっきれなかった動画ですね
何な頃オーナー号店だ秋の上からの絵が撮れなくてやってたんだ
さっき
[音楽]
いやー
なつかじゃあ舌ね暇すぎだ4つにやらせましたことでこれ最近ですねなんだ
家の外でもまださあ剣舞またなんかはじめ
初めて叫ぶ中学生と超えたんでもう結構怒って梅ちゃんご注意しました
懲りずにまだやルーンのかなぁすごいねこれはあれですね金襴ボイド田中が猛烈に遊び
にきたときにあの日か審査の彼をゲット買ってるダメってました
本当に町ラベルが本当またそうねそれはついさんでしょ
寝てるのか
寝てるねーー
まだ髪の毛があるべきだ膝きたなぁ
[音楽]
水かけようとしたけど
やめたんだよ
優しいのねこれではツイッターで出したと思うんですけど何か
仮面ライダーエグゼいいのかなエグゼ井戸の年間ゲームがすぐ面白くて変身できるん
ですよ
[音楽]
ページにしましたん
ほら兵士しても2号線なんですよ動きがやっぱ
変えみたいで結構ハイリスクはざっと見ているためこれは良かったです
電気ビリー3 t た月大便器ビデオなかっ
うわぁ寝てるので切り明治業務だがそういったなって楽しかったですこれも前期3
レベルですね
[音楽]
何時するようなんだよ俺なんでこれスローでしたんだろう
おおこれは誰と電気ビリビリぷな奴なんですよ
[音楽]
ああああああ
ザトーン
[音楽]
俺が女ならなんか人のいたがあるがばっかり言って楽しんでるからこのなくなんか哲也
と車で移動してたらなんかそれ原付の人が楽しそうに体振りながら運転してあぶねえ
なあって思ったところですね
あと車がすごい汚かったです編集してるとミックさんですねやっぱりとミックさんは
正面から見るより横で見たほうが
たく力があるんでちょっとよ
この辺も押さえておこうかなと思って横の絵を抑えてみました
秋津いたん
普通とずレア
あくびでしたこれの徹夜の服ガーナー言ってたんです
いろんな食感すぐ後安かったのでめっちゃ打って上げて覚える
すごい痛いんですよラブライブのでかいのが車走っていたので感動して撮ったんだけっ
ていう
文具だね踵しカードをもらったんですけどそれが何かわからなくて
負けるやつだった気がします
何だけこれを舌を覚えているようないますよね
のまだあるよえっ
ん
いますね
はい
んはああーーーーっっっ
俺の顔が貼ってありましたはいというわけでいかがだったでしょうか
なんかやっぱね行動がだとなんかちゃんとしなきゃなーとか思っちゃったりするんで目
がこういうスマホの動画ってなかなか
まあれあかなと思って黒瀬もやってみました9でもまたスマホで変な動画いろいろ撮っ
てまたねまずに障害者と思います次の動画でましょう
ズンッ
[音楽]
ん